[Music]
hey everyone its Alicia Malone welcome
back to another Fandango indie movie
guide I am fresh back from Telluride and
Toronto and I missed talking to you guys
about mother which came out in theaters
last week I want to know what did you
think of that crazy film you know I
really enjoyed the madness of it I loved
a movie that you can walk out of and you
want to debate it with your friends and
some people love it and some people hate
it and you delve into the meaning of
everything but you know I know it's not
for everyone
it was Darren Aronofsky's allegorical
film about the creation of the earth as
well as the environment starring
Jennifer Lawrence
ed Harris Javier Bardem and Michelle
Pfeiffer who was just wonderful let me
know in the comments below what did you
think of mother do you think it deserved
the F CinemaScore that it was given it's
not technically in Indy but it
definitely has that original Indy spirit
about it but let's get on to what you
can see in theaters this week battle of
the sexes starring Steve Carell and Emma
Stone had a great run both at Telluride
and Toronto this is a very accessible
very feel-good inspirational true tale
of Billie Jean King the feminist tennis
champion who took on the very
chauvinistic Bobby Riggs in a literal
battle of the sexes a tennis match where
she wanted to prove that women belonged
on the court just as much as men look
the men are simply more exciting to
watch they are they're faster facts and
they're stronger act and they're more
competitive just the fact it's not your
fault it's just biology it's the kind of
true story which you wouldn't quite
believe if it weren't actually true it's
got great performances by Emma and Steve
and just a heartwarming feel-good tale
it'll have you clapping and smiling the
whole way through
so we want a little bit of what you've
got that's what you can't stand 40
million people are watching the Battle
of you've all been waiting there
also in theaters this weekend stronger
which also played at the Toronto
International Film Festival this stars
feature husband Jake Gyllenhaal as Jeff
Bauman who lost his legs in the Boston
bombing and I think this movie is really
interesting when it takes a look at what
it means to be a hero particularly in
today's scary times I'm gonna be there
at the finish line for anything you go
with Jeff as he struggles in the
aftermath of the tragedy and tried to
cope with the sudden rush of Fame with
people calling him a hero where he says
he was just unlucky in the in the wrong
place at the wrong time but his story
really does show that true Boston strong
spirit you saw the war that they can't
break us no matter what the hell they do
give me a little hope made me feel a
little thank you that's all Jake
Gyllenhaal
once again puts in a fantastic
performance Tatiana maslany is wonderful
as always she's so real and relatable
and I really liked miranda Richardson
who played the mother who is crass and
uncouth and very loud and bombastic
stronger will have you feeling all the
emotions and make sure you take your
tissues when he said in theaters this
weekend I'm gonna walk with ullians from
there
and on Fandango now two great indie
titles to check out in the comfort of
your own home the first one the hero
which came out on the 12th and this is
well worth a look it stars Sam Elliot in
a great performance very massive
performance where he plays an aging
western star who's trying to figure out
his place in Hollywood he's trying to
mend his broken relationship with his
daughter he's dealing with a fling with
someone who is much much younger and he
is also quite sick I did one film that
I'm proud of it that was 40 years ago
attention it would have been achieving
so he has a lot going on and it's all
anchored by the Rocksteady gorgeous
presence of Sam Elliott I really liked
the hero directed by Brett Haley so
check it out on Fandango now and a film
that was quite divisive with audiences a
ghost story is now available to watch on
Fandango now this is directed by David
Lowery and it stars Rooney Mara and
Casey Affleck right at the beginning of
the film this marriage between this
young couple is rocked when he dies of a
car accident and then he comes back as a
ghost
so basically Casey Affleck walks around
underneath the sheet for most of the
movie and there is also an entire scene
that goes on for about five minutes
without any cuts of Rooney Mara eating a
pie apparently she'd never eaten a pie
before in her life and she never wants
to eat pie again but it looked really
delicious a writer writes a novel a song
writer writes a song we do we
to endure I love this kind of thing you
know it might be a bit artsy and out
there for some people but every scene is
there for a purpose and it has beautiful
cinematography by Andrew Joss Palomo it
all looks like a home movie with the
edges rounded and there's something so
mythical about just that white sheet
it's haunting and also kind of comical
at the same time it's all about whether
you can have true eternal love give it a
go watch it at home on Fandango now
[Music]
so let's run through them quickly I
recommend in theaters to try out the
madness of mother or go for the
feel-good story of battle of the sexes
or the inspirational true story of
stronger if you want to stay at home
with Fandango now you can see Sam Elliot
in the gorgeous drama the hero or maybe
try to go a little bit arty and see
Rooney Mara in a ghost story
I'm Alicia Malone you can always find me
on Twitter at Alicia Malone and I'll see
you again next week bye
[Music]